>>> AND WE'RE BACK WITH OUR
WORLD LEAD.
A DAY OF INTENSE FIGHTING ON THE
EASTERN FRONT OF UKRAINE.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE AFTERMATH
OF UKRAINIAN SHELLING IN DONETSK
WHERE RUSSIAN LEADERS SAY AT
LEAST FOUR PEOPLE WERE KILLED
TUESDAY.
AND TODAY, JUST 30 MILES TO THE
WEST, UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS SAY AT
LEAST CIVILIANS WERE KILLED BY
RUSSIAN STRIKES.
SAM KYLIE IS AT A HOSPITAL WHERE
WOUNDS INFLICTED BY MODERN
WEAPONS OF WAR REQUIRE
INNOVATIVE, LIFE SAVING
TECHNIQUES.
>> Reporter: WARTIME BRAIN
SURGERY IN TANDEM.
WOUNDED IN BATTLE ON THE SAME
DAY ON THE SAME FRONT, TWO YOUNG
MEN.
THE FOCUS OF THESE OVERPRACTICED
NEUROSURGEONS.
IT IS OFTEN BOMBED, THE WINDOWS
EVEN IN HERE ARE TAPED THE SLOW
FLYING GLASS.
THE EFFORT IS INTENSE TO REPAIR
BRAINS, TO SAVE LIVES, MEMORIES,
LOVE AND FUTURE DREAMS.
THEY WOULD HAVE LITTLE IDEA
WHERE TO START THEIR DELICATE
WORK IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE USE OF
THIS CT SCANNER.
IT CAN PINPOINT DAMAGE, FIND
WHAT IT'S DONE, AND IT GIVES
SURGEONS A PLAN OF ACTION.
HE SAYS YES, AN UNFORTUNATELY,
THERE IS NO LEFT EYE.
THERE'S A SUSPICION OF DAMAGE TO
THE RIGHT EYE AS WELL, BUT
DEFINITELY NO LEFT EYE.
THIS IS THE FOURTH PATIENT WE'VE
SEEN IN THE SPACE OF ABOUT AN
HOUR COME IN FOR A CT SCAN.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE DOING 15 OR
20 A DAY.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING 70 OR 80.
IN SHORT, IT'S WEARING OUT.
THIS EQUIPMENT IS VITAL.
THE HOSPITAL CAN'T AFFORD A NEW
ONE BUT THE USED ONE FOR SALE IN
THE WEST OF UKRAINE COST ABOUT
120,000 BUCKS.
THE COST OF USING THIS ONE,
INCAL CUABLE.
HE SAYS HE SHOWS SIGN OF
HEMATOMA AND BRAIN CONTUSION.
HE NEEDS URGENT SURGERY.
THE ADMINISTRATORS HERE HAVE
RAISED ABOUT $60,000.
THEY NEED HELP WITH THE REST.
THIS IS THE ONLY CT SCANNER IN A
VAST REGION.
CRITICAL, THIS MACHINE IS
CRITICAL.
CT IS CRITICAL TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE CARE FOR PATIENTS
WITH BOTH HEAD WOUNDS AND ACUTE
BRAIN INJURIES.
>> IS IT SAVING LIVES?
DEFINITELY, ABSOLUTELY.
100%.
>> THERE'S BEEN A STEADY FLOW OF
SOLDIERS INJURED NEARBY.
THE SCENE OF THE HEAVIEST
FIGHTING.
THIS IS A HOSPITAL THAT IS
TRYING TO DEAL REALLY WITH AN
AREA THEY SAY ABOUT 300 SQUARE
KILOMETERS AND A LOT OF THAT IS
AT WAR.
SOME SOLDIERS ARE RELATIVELY
LUCKY.
THE RUSSIANS SHOT MORTARS BACK.
MY COMMANDER WAS LUCKY.
HE SAT IN FRONT OF ME AND I SAT
BEHIND HIM AND HE WAS UNHURT.
I GOT HIT IN THE LEG, BUT YEAH,
WE'VE SEEN WOUNDED AND DEAD
BEFORE.
IF I'M SITTING HERE, I'M LUCKY.
UKRAINIANS ON THIS EASTERN FRONT
CALL IT THE MEAT GRINDER.
CHET WAS ALONGSIDE DUCK WHEN
THEY WERE HIT.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THE
BATTLE?
HE SAYS WHILE TRENCHES, BLOOD,
MUD, TRENCH WARFARE.
THAT'S IT.
WORLD WAR I AND II.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT MODERN
WEAPONS ARE NOW MORE POWERFUL.
MODERN SURGERY, OFTEN THE ONLY
ROUTE TO SURVIVAL.
THAT AND OLD FASHIONED GRIT.
>> NOW, JAKE, THAT HOSPITAL AND
INDEED OTHER HOSPITALS I VISITED
ON THIS FRONT LINE, IS HAVING TO
HEAT ITSELF USING SELF-INSTALLED
BOILERS.
BURNING ANYTHING FROM RUBBISH
THROUGH TO COAL AND WOOD.
THEY ARE SHORT OF ELECTRICITY
BECAUSE OF THE RUSSIAN ATTACKS
ON THE ELECTRICAL SYSTEMS.
FREQUENTLY, THEY ARE HIT WITH
POWER CUTS.
THEY HAVE TO RESORT TO
GENERATORS.
OF COURSE, THEY NEED CT SCANS,
MRIs AND THE WOUNDED KEEP
POURING IN, JAKE.
THIS IS A FEROCIOUS FRONT LINE
AS BOTH THE RUSSIANS AND
UKRAINIANS HAVE SHIFTED THEIR
SOLDIERS FROM THE SOUTHERN
BATTLES UP TO THIS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AS THE HEAVY FIGHTING RAGES ON,
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SPENT THE
DAY VISITING WOUNDED TROOPS,
PRESENTING MEDALS OF HONOR.
ONE TO AN AMERICAN FIGHTER WHO
VOLUNTEERED FOR UKRAINE.
THE SAME DAY, TIME MAGAZINE
NAMED ZELENSKYY AND SPIRIT OF
UKRAINE AS ITS PERSON OF THE
YEAR.
CLARISSA WARD HAS BEEN FOLLOWING
THE EVOLUTION OF PUTIN'S BRUTAL
WAR SINCE THE BEGINNING.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THAT YOU'RE SAFE.
TODAY, PUTIN SAID THE THREAT OF
NUCLEAR WAR IS INCREASING.
WE'VE SEEN HIM SABER RATTLING
BEFORE, BUT AS THE WAR DRAGS ON
AND HIS STOCKPILES OF
TRADITIONAL WEAPONS DEPLETE, DO
YOU THINK THIS THREAT OF USING A
NUKE BECOMES MORE REAL?
>> THE THREAT DEFINITELY BECOMES
MORE REAL AND THE THREAT CAN'T
BE DISCOUNTED, CERTAINLY, BUT I
THINK WHAT YOU HEARD IF YOU
LISTEN TO PUTIN'S ENTIRE
COMMENTS TODAY WAS KIND OF A
TYPICAL EXAMPLE OF HIM TRYING TO
PLAY BOTH SIDES.
HE SAID OF COURSE WE'RE NOT
CRAZY.
WE'D NEVER BE THE FIRST TO USE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WE ONLY HAVE THEM AS A
DETERRENT, BUT THEN AT THE SAME
TIME, HE SAYS BUT THE RISK IS
INCREASING AND BY THE WAY, OURS
ARE MORE MODERN AND MORE
SOPHISTICATED THAN YOURS ARE.
SO ON THE ONE HAND, HE'S TRYING
TO DIFFUSE THE SITUATION WHILE
ON THE OTHER, HE'S CONTINUING
THE STOKE IT BECAUSE THE THREAT
OF THE NUCLEAR WEAPONS IS ALMOST
MORE IMPORTANT TO HIM THAN THE
ACTUAL USE OF THEM.
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT THAT CARRIES
SUCH A DEEP FEAR.
NOT JUST WITH UKRAINIANS, BUT
WITH PEOPLE ALL AROUND THE
WORLD.
SO THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
LEAVER FOR HIM TO HAVE AT HIS
BECK AND CALL.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY'RE SAYING
WE DON'T SEE ANY INDICATION HE'S
PREPARING TO USE THEM.
>> ONE THAT HE IS USE SG THIS
MERCENARY GROUP RUN BY ONE OF
THE OLIGARCHS.
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT HIM
BEFORE.
THIS WEEK, HE WARNED THE U.S.
NOT TO PROVOKE HIS GROUP BY
DESIGNATING THE VOGNER GROUP A
TERROR ORGANIZATION.
YOU COVERED THE GROUP FOR YEARS,
EVEN TRACKED AND INTIMIDATED, OR
AT LEAST TRIED TO INTIMIDATE
YOU.
WHEN THEY ISSUE A WARNING LIKE
THIS, QUOTE, LET SLEEPING DOGS
LIE, DO NOT WAKE VOGNER.
HOW SERIOUS DOES THE U.S. NEED
TO TAKE THIS.
>> THEY REALLY RELY HEAVILY ON
THE MYTH OF WAGNER GROUP.
THEY RELISH IN THEIR BRUTALITY
AND NOW THAT WE'VE SEEN HIM COME
OUT OF THE SHADOWS AND CLAIM A
MORE PUBLIC ROLE AND TALK ABOUT
THE NEED TO CARPET BOMB UKRAINE,
I THINK THEY'RE PLAYING UP TO
THAT BRUTALITY EVEN MORE.
WHEN WE WERE IN THE CENTRAL
AFRICAN REPUBLIC DOING THAT
STORY AND TALKING TO U.S.
OFFICIALS, THE SORT OF MESSAGE
WE WERE GIVEN IS DON'T GIVE
THESE GUYS TOO MUCH CREDIT.
THEY'RE PRETTY INCOMPETENT AND
NOT THAT EFFECTIVE.
FAST FORWARD TO WHERE WE ARE
NOW, I THINK THERE ARE STILL
REAL ISSUES SURROUNDING WHETHER
OR NOT THEY'RE CONFIDENT AND HOW
MUCH OF AN IMPACT THEY'RE HAVING
ON THE BATTLEFIELD IN UKRAINE,
BUT THEY'RE A SIGNIFICANT FORCE
AND WHAT MAKES THEM DANGEROUS
AND DIFFICULT IS THEY DON'T
ANSWER TO ANYONE OFFICIALLY.
THERE IS NO ACCOUNTABILITY FOR A
GROUP LIKE WAGNER AND AS WE HAVE
BEEN SEEN IN SOME OF THESE
HORRIFIC EXECUTION VIDEOS, THEY
ARE WILLING TO STOOP TO ACTS OF
GREAT BRUTALITY TO ACHIEVE THEIR
OBJECTIVES.
>> DOESN'T T